ممر صورك شريط ضيق يبلغ طوله 70 كيلومترا
ويربط بين بيلاروسيا وكارلينجراد التي تقع
على بحر البلطيق والتي ضمها جوزيف ستالين
للاتحاد السوفيتي بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه واصبحت روسيه بعد انهيار الاتحاد
يتميز ممر السوالكي بموقع جغرافي فريد فهو
يقع فوق اراضي ليتوانيا على حدودها مع
بولندا ويربط بين اراد روسيه وبلاروسيه
وتمر عبره في الوقت العادي عشرات القطارات
في اليوم فما هي ظروف نشاته
في عام 2003 وقبيل انضمام ليتوانيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي وقع الاتحاد مع روسيا
اتفاقا يسمح بمرور البضائع والسلع بين
بيلاروسيا وجيبي كالينينجراد الروسي لكن
ليتوانيا رفضت مطالب روسيه بالسماح بوجود
عسكري روسي في الممر بعد اندلاع حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا وتعزيز الوجود العسكري
الروسي في بيلاروسيا ازدادت مخاوف دول حلف
الناتو من امكانيه تفكير رئيس الروسي في
السيطره على الممر خصوصا وان الجيشين
الروسي والبيلاروسي اجرى يا مناورات تحاكي
السيطره عليه فهذه السيطره اذا تمت تعني
فصلا تاما لدول البلطيق
الثلاثه عن باقي دول حلف النيتو بالاضافه
الى تضييق الخناق على بولندا في المقابل
فبعد انضمام فنلندا وسويد لحلف النيتو
يصبح عزل كالينغراد حيث مقر اسطول
البلطيقه الروسي امرا ممكنا اذا اغلق
ممرسوالكي اذا يعتبر حلف النيتو الممر
نقطته الرخوه الاخطر ويرفض الروس اغلاقه
الذي يعني حصار